hi everyone it's joanna here and guess
who's back with me hi guys it's hazley
so to kick start this new year what will
we be doing haas all right we will be
doing a body weight strength training
all right for the whole body all right
in which this is suitable for everyone
of all levels especially if you're just
about to start your workout journey yes
that's right so we will be taking it
easy to start off with and we will
progress through the workout session
okay so let's get your body ready and
let's do this together
all right everyone before we start into
the first round of four exercises let's
warm the body up first open your legs
just slightly hip width apart and let's
start with some torso rotations release
your heel
and rotate
so joanna will be showing the different
versions of options all right the
regress version so if you can't follow
the movements that i'm doing always look
at joanna for the easier option yeah now
let's reach out your arms
all right so get that shoulders as well
stretching out
and we're going to slowly reach up
good
heart rate is also coming up
all right joints are all warming up as
well
okay guys now roll the arms forward
that's it
and we're gonna take it to the back
good
okay now everyone just side to side
lunges
soft knees
just small ones yeah just to warm up
those hip flexors and get the lower body
moving
that's nice
all right can we do some hip openness
come on standing just open the hip and
switch the other side that's the one try
to find your balance immediately start
engaging your core all right to help you
perform this movement with good
stability
so we have a lot of lower body movements
as well in this workout today
let's shift it to leg swings so just
swing your leg forward and try to keep a
balance all right by engaging your core
give me a few more right here
and let's switch to the other side as
well
that's the one
all right guys can we bring the heart
rate up so give me a light jog
all right just to get the heart rate up
so in today's three rounds of work it
will be low impact so we will not be
jumping we'll always be on the ground so
i need you to focus on muscle activation
as well as technique throughout the
three rounds of work all right guys
okay
so shake it off all right guys just
shake it all off now we're going to
start with the first movement soon so
just to warm it up i just need you to
give me small hip hinges push the butt
back and come up to squeeze the glutes
activate the glute push the butt back
just a small one yeah
push the butt back and come back up
that's it all right guys the first
movement that we're going to start is
with your right leg right right leg
and we're going to go with a squat and a
front
lunge all right so open your legs
shoulder width apart toes slightly
pointed outwards you're going to start
with your right leg all right so squat
and forward lunge in three
two one round one here we go
drop down and then step forward
and come back here and then squat down
all right i don't need you to rush what
i need you to do is really focus on that
movement
drop it down always keeping the knees
aligned to the toes
and always coming up squeezing the
glutes engaging the core
and dropping it down good
all right guys
we're gonna shift to the side of your
mat very soon
that's it
and come to the side of your mat 30
seconds inch worm and lift your right
hand up for a side plank watch this
inchworm out
and then lift your right hand up
come back up only the right side guys
only the right side
and squeeze the glutes bring it down
feel the hamstring stretch there engage
your core shift the core stabilization
to your obliques and come up
nice
there we go guys good job building good
foundation here building good strength
here all right come back up we're gonna
squat and now we move to the left lunge
let's go one squat
and one lunge
nice and easy drop
and forward
drop forward so
you're getting the techniques and the
movements in the first set
second set we go for it and third set
everything you got yeah
nice
four
three
two
one let's come
and drop down this time left hand up
roll it up
left hand up perfect and drop it down
squeeze that glute go down
abs tight and push
guys we can do one more of this
and then you get a short break yeah
[Music]
all right come back up
and relax shake it off 30 seconds break
just take a little light jog same thing
guys second set four movements you've
done we're just going to do the same
thing all over again you know how it
looks like now so commit a little bit
more into the movement i want you to
focus on feeling the muscles in this
round all right now let's set up for the
same thing set number two toe slightly
pointed outwards
heels to your shoulder width and let's
get ready three two one drop it down one
squat right leg please forward and back
in
i'm going to show you a side view
joanna's going to continue from the
front view this is how it's going to
look from the side
drop it down
forward and up yeah drop it down
got it again let's go
squeeze
at the top i need you to now focus on
feeling the glute squeeze
all right gang four
three
two let's come to the side of your mat
oh inchworm gang down
and right hand only
bring it down come back up
and go down
this is a good way to activate the core
and improve your balance at the same
time
all right gang let's go for it again
give you one more last one
nice come up
all right back to the center of your mat
gang
squat and now left lunge
one drop
one left lunge and come back up
nice
good joanna
all right let's go for it
feeling good
all right getting no rush like i said
focusing on the technique focusing on
the movement
all right
you get those results you want
five
four
three
two
one all right guys side of your mat
let's go
touch the floor and left hand up
bring it back down
squeeze the glute engage that core down
you go again down you go again come on
turn
reach drop
okay guys we have one more time
bring it down
good
take it up
release and all the way back up
all right shake it off good guys 30
seconds rest now we have one final set
this final step same four exercises
round one you've seen the movement round
two you've tried and feel the muscles
involved and round three is for you to
push okay so torso rotation take it easy
now the first movement is your squat to
lunge right leg okay now let's set up
for that squat for that final set of
this round heels shoulder width apart
hands in front of you raise that core
in three two one one squat right leg
forward
and then let's go
yep
now
squeeze the butt at the top and forward
down low guys come on
let's take this up a notch and drop it
low and come up
drop it low come up
that's it
okay again 10 more seconds to go
hold on with me five more five
four
three
two and let's go to the end of your math
right hand
for the inchworm
right hand up
bring it back down and crawl back up now
i need you to really focus with me when
you come down when you reach that plank
position engage that ab first then only
lift that arm up yeah
keep your hip and your butt
in a nice neutral slope
no piking up coming back down
all right guys let's come back to the
center of your mat let's squat again
squat and this time
left lunge good
squat
left lunge and up
all right let's go
drink and up
[Music]
okay 10 more seconds with this
[Music]
all right five
four
three
two
one squat back off the mat let's go down
touch touch
abs tight left hand up and then touch
back down good
so you never let go of this yes bring it
down
squeeze tight
lift up
tap down
come back up
can we do one more finish it strong
round one finishing
good job gang lifts up
touch down
come back up
and
shake it off guys good job so there was
round one take a one minute break quick
drink of water and come back for round
two
[Music]
[Applause]
okay everyone welcome back so round two
we will be down on the floor where we
will be doing a kickback to a fire
hydrant yeah then after that down to the
floor first let me just show you the
movement
come up here
on all fours so your palm will be
directly under your shoulder blades and
your knee under your hip so what you're
going to do is starting off with the
right leg we're going to do a kickback
come forward
and to the side with the fire hydrant
yeah and then the next movement will be
an open close push-up so you can go on
your knees
one push-up
and we're going to just open on the
right side focus on one side first all
right steady guys on all fours let's go
right leg kick back
come in
and fire hydrant to the side when you're
doing this movement
i need you to focus to stabilize your
lower back
engage your core so that you are not
making sudden big movements around your
core region yeah
30 seconds here push
come back and lift nice
not yet
you really feel that 3d work on the
glutes here again and
come down
all right so you can be on your knees
with joanna or you can come up with me
full all right so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go one push up
come up
shift open to the right
come up come back
and drop only the right hand first gang
right up
drop
and down good in
drop
up
open
squeeze
up nice and steady again good all about
control
elbow is about 45 degrees away from the
body come back in on all fours
left leg fire hydrant and kick back
first come back and open to the side
good squeeze the glute
and up to the side good
that's it that's it
balance the body
[Music]
try to avoid overarching your lower back
focus all on the glutes
and keep your core engaged at all times
all right guys up we go push up yeah
plank position
one push up and this time left hand goes
out
push so whenever you move the palm
that's when you need to engage the core
keep your balance
and then come back to a position for the
push-up yeah
elbow is 45 degrees away you're doing
fine joanna yes getting strong strong
and in control yes
upper body yep
three
two
one
all right stay down guys shake it off
just normal roll your shoulders forward
yep and then roll your shoulder back
good we're going to repeat the same
thing now
so step one is done we're going to go to
set two i really want you to feel the
muscles working here so from the glutes
up to the chest on the push-ups all
right here we go on all fours
engage the core knee on the hip
palms on the shoulder right leg
let's go
kick back
and side so feel the glute squeeze it up
come down and then to the side glutes
yep
lift
so this is why we call it more or less
like a 3d workout for your glutes
because we're hitting it in different
angles
good
all right gang
exhale every time you lift your leg up
yeah inhale when you bring it down
three
two one more please and drop
come into your push-up position on your
knees or on your toes your choice and
let's go one push come up shift open and
drop
nice
when you bring your body down
try to squeeze your shoulder
blades back
for good control and come back up
good
almost there again you have five
four
three
two
one
up good on all fours now left side and
great embrace the core
kick back come back
fire hydrant and then again
good
squeeze that glute come back
and go
so remember to bring it up to a point
where you do not over arch your lower
back yep just feeling the glutes squeeze
it and that's enough
[Music]
three two
one all right gang push up position
on your toes on your knees your choice
let's go let's go come on up
squeeze the chest open
drop
and up
nice
so like joanna say upper body is getting
stronger yeah totally totally feeling my
chest and arms you can feel your chest
that's what we want
okay you should feel some in your
triceps is working all right
two
one
okay okay short break now it's your
final set for round two all right roll
the shoulder forward
in this set
control and technique is still there but
we go further by trying to push even
more do not give up let's get the
repetitions in
okay
all right guys set up for the final set
of this round
kick back to fire hydrant break that
core
and three two one let's go
hit come in and reach good
nice one guys
so i'm sure you've gotten this movement
by now
so you really just focus on getting that
repetition a beautiful repetition done
one after another yeah
10 more seconds
you can really feel those glutes
coming into play here three
two
one
okay gang come on up to push up position
ready let's go one push squeeze the
chest opened it drop it
and that's it
okay almost there gang 10 more seconds
stay with me
five
four
three
two
one come up on all fours
nice
now left leg come on kick back
come in
and lift to the side good kick back
come in
lift to the side
feels good gang come on
ten more seconds
and let's finish strong with upper body
yes
five
four
three
two
one okay
come on up push up and let's finish the
strong brace that core come down
squeeze it
open
and drop
nice
all right gang
so
you're almost there finishing this third
set of round two strong
five
four
three
two
one
and that's it
rest shake it off you're good joanna yes
all right guys final one minute break
take a drink of water and see you back
in a bit again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay guys are you ready for round three
are you ready for round two i am so
ready for round three okay we're gonna
finish this very strong round three four
exercises three sets you know the drill
alright so we're gonna start standing
and then we're gonna go into a plank
position first movement will be
basically a curtsy lunch you're gonna
drop down
and then open to a side lunge yep so
that's your first movement and then
you're gonna follow with a plank
shoulder tap
all right guys we're gonna finish this
strong yes deal
all right all right gang so i'm gonna
stand here
all right slightly more to the side so
that i can curtsy and open yeah in four
three right leg two
one and then curtsy toes pointed forward
side lunge let's go
curtsy lunge so we're gonna try and step
and step back immediately drop or you
can step to the center first like joanna
if you have problem with balance
all right or just go out
and go back with me immediately yeah
your choice
squeeze that glute
drop it down
and
that's it all right guys let's come down
to the floor you can plank on your knees
or on the toes come to a plank position
hold the core brace it and start
shoulder tapping one at a time all right
no rush
the challenge here is to keep your core
engaged while you move your palms
touching your shoulder that's the
challenge yeah so try not to move the
hip too much when you are tapping up
hold it in and tap
tap
good let's come up
curtsy lunge guys now left leg's going
to lead let's go drop back
toes forward
out yeah
drop back
and out
so your choice to take a short break in
the center here and come out
and here and come back or just forward
and drop
forward and drop your choice
where you are today
that's your challenge yes
and coming down now crouching tiger push
up you're gonna come
to a beast position
and then forward to a push-up
all right when you come to a push-up
position you can go to your knees
and push up like joanna yeah or you can
come up
all the way on your toes for the push-up
and come down
yeah
nice
forward abs tight drop
up
and back
all right gang
short break how are you guys feeling so
far so fast
so far so good finishing strong okay so
you have two more sets same thing we're
alternating upper body and lower body
okay so this final
round is really a total body workout
okay all about control you guys ready
for set number two cut c2 side lunge you
know your option pick it
choose it commit and let's get ready in
three
two
one let's go curtsy lift
and drop
lift and drop your choice
lift up or tap down
okay
so tapping down look at joanna tapping
and then to the back and then tapping
all right you find your balance you find
your challenge yep
that's it gang nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one plank position now come down
set number two strong abs tight and
whenever you're ready
tap the shoulder
reduce the movement from the hip
engage that core
nice
good gain
five
four three
two
one come on up
you're gonna go cut see left leg
curtsy back
lift up
and side lunge
there we go
up
drop
good
so always keep your spine neutral
all right
don't drop your body too far to the
front
five
four guys come on three
two
one
okay crouching tiger push up
choose your push up option
beast mode forward and push up up
nice
elbow 45 degrees away from the body
stretch it out
abs tight
drop it down
stretch out good
very good very big compound movement
using the whole body to lead the way
three
two
one
huh
all right joanna ready to finish this i
am so ready one final set yes final set
guys we're with you all the way till the
end all right stay with us stay with us
we're gonna finish this new workout
strong
okay guys stand up
we're gonna go with your curtsy to your
side lunch ready to commit for the final
set ready joanna yep all right let's
take it home in four
three
two
one good see
drop
up
side lunge good
good job gang come on come on
every time you come up you lead with the
leading leg push your body up
push your body up
good guys you have 10 seconds
down over to a plank
choose your option brace the core and
start tapping that shoulder
there we go
all right no rush all about control
all about commitment and your power
all right stay here
abs tight
guys you have seven
six
five
four
three
two
one come out standing
curtsy left leg back
up we go
and side lunge there we go
nice
okay lift
drop
up
down good up
10 seconds to go
seven
six come on gang five
four
three
two
one
all right
crouching push up
here we go beast mode
and forward
push up shoot up strong and come back
forward here we go up
almost there gang 10 more seconds
finish it strong with me come on
seven
six
five four
three
two squeeze one push up one
ah
all right big high five joanna
all right so now let us cool down
everyone come on to seated position i
need you to just slowly take your palms
interlace your fingers lift your body
forward and then push forward
release those shoulders
all right good one
good one and slowly push all the way up
nice
can we open up the chest we've done a
lot of push-ups today bring your palms
together to the back interlace your
fingers
push it down
chin up to the ceiling open the chest
nice
hold on here
good
shall we stretch our lower body let's
come up
okay everyone come up standing in the
middle of your mat let's take down bring
your legs just hip width apart
now
drop down fingers as low as you can
stretch out your hamstring if you can
touch your toe touch your toe all right
and stretch
your hamstrings
all right slowly bring your palm up to
your thighs
extend your back forward
nice
stretch for the spine
keep your eye gaze 45 degrees to the
ground
and come up
all right guys take your right leg
behind your left and then lift your
right hand up all the way stretch out
extend high to the ceiling
hold it here
bring it down
let's switch it to the other side and
reach
good
come back
let's finish this with three big breaths
inhale up one
exhale down
two
out one more hold it up at the top hold
your breath for five counts hold five
four
three
two big release one go
all right one more big high five joanna
amazing job husley
that was so good i really felt my total
body working and i love all the compound
movements so this workout is really
great for beginners or for those of you
who haven't been working out for quite
some time and you decided that this year
it's going to be your year to start
getting active again so haas how did you
feel
i really enjoyed the workout it's a good
way to start the year it really gets the
whole body moving and you know it's
about reactivating those body parts yeah
correct that's right so i hope you
enjoyed this workout well be sure to
check out a lot more workout videos on
my youtube channel and you will also
find some cooking recipes together with
hazley on my youtube channel and also a
lot more fitness tips so
let's kick start 2022 strong and let's
end this year's strong as well we got it
alright guys see you again all the best
bye